Welcome back.
We're on problem number 13.
And actually, I started problem
number 13 at the end
of the last video, and then I
realized when I was going
through the choices that
I wasn't explaining
it perfectly correctly.
And I have to admit, this is the
first problem that of any
of the problems we've seen on
the SAT, this is probably the
one that-- the wording
is probably the most
difficult to interpret.
But I think I've figured
it out now.
So they're saying Kyle's lock
combination consists of three
two digit numbers.
The combination satisfies
three conditions below.
One number is odd, one number
is a multiple of 5, so we'll
just write that as times 5, and
then one number is a day
of the month of Kyle's
birthday.
And actually, this is what
confused me, it actually
matters that it's his birthday,
not that it's just a
day of the month, and
I'll show you why.
So let's say we have choice A.
And let me color code
these conditions.
So odd I'll do in
this blue color.
Let me see, and times 5
in this yellow color.
And then-- let me pick another
good color-- brown, the day of
the month of his birthday.
So the first choice-- and now
let me write these down in a
fairly neutral color,
in this magenta.
So choice A says
14, 20, and 13.
So what we can do is, let's see,
one of the numbers has to
be odd, and only one of
the numbers, right?
So let's say this one.
This satisfies the odd
condition, and actually only
satisfies the odd condition.
Then let's see, what number
here is times 5,
a multiple of 5?
Well, this number-- let me do it
in the yellow-- this number
is a multiple of 5.
And then, finally, if that one
is the multiple of 5, which
one has to be the day of the
month of his birthday?
Well, it's this choice,
right here.
Now what confused me, when I
first did this problem, and
probably confused you as well,
it says if each number
satisfies exactly one of the
conditions-- exactly one,
exactly one, right?
So to me that means that it can
only satisfy one of the
conditions.
And what confused me was that 20
satisfies multiple of five,
but to me 20 could just
as easily be a
day of a month, right?
But the problem that this
encounters is here we have to
kind of assume that the
14th is his birthday.
Because-- let's put it this
way-- if the 20th was his
birthday, this works
if, and only if,
the 14th is his birthday.
Which it could be.
And if the 14th is his birthday,
then 20 doesn't
satisfy the day of the month
of his birthday.
It satisfies a day of the month,
it wouldn't satisfy the
day of the month of
his birthday.
That might seem a little
technical, but I think you'll
see why I have to make that
distinction, as you go
on to choice B.
Choice B says-- let me do it in
that neutral color-- it's
14, 25, and 13.
So here, once again, 13
satisfies the odd criteria.
We could say that 14-- we'll
assume that his birthday is
the 14th, we don't know, they
haven't told us, but
it could be, right?
That's what they're asking, what
could be the combination
of the lock.
So we'll say that the 14th
could be his birthday.
And if the 14th is
his birthday,
what does 25 satisfy?
Well, 25 now satisfies the odd
criteria, and it satisfies the
multiple of 5 criteria.
So this option, choice
B, does not work.
Because 25 satisfies two
of the criteria.
And I know what you're saying,
well look, in choice A,
doesn't 20 satisfy
two criteria?
Doesn't it satisfy that it could
be a day of the month?
And what I'm saying is, if we
assume that the 14th is his
birthday, than 20
does not satisfy
the day of his birthday.
Right?
We're assuming the 14th
is his birthday.
I want you to think
that about it.
20 satisfies a potential day of
the month, but if we assume
his birthday is the 14th,
then obviously
20th is not the 14th.
And we could go through
the other choices.
Choice C says 15-- let
me do it in a neutral
color-- 15, 18, 16.
And here, let's say one
of them has to be odd.
There's only one odd option
here, it's this one.
One of them has to be
a multiple of 5.
Well, there's no multiples of
5 here, so we know that C is
not the right answer.
D-- 20, 15, 20.
Well here we have two of the
same number, so they're going
to satisfy the same criteria.
So they're each either going
to satisfy two criteria, or
they're each going
to satisfy none.
And they actually both satisfy--
you know, there's
only one odd one here, so one of
the 20's has to satisfy the
day of the month of
his birthday.
But if the day of the month of
his birthday is 20th, and then
we used the multiple of five
as being the 20th as well,
then both of these numbers
satisfy the day of his
birthday, and a multiple of 5.
So that can't be the choice.
Then E, choice E-- let me do it
in a neutral color again--
is 34, 30, 21.
And see 34, it's not odd, it's
not a multiple of 5, and it
can't be a day of the month of
someone's birthday, so that
one doesn't work.
I think these three are
obvious to you,
why they don't work.
Here the subtlety is that
this criteria isn't just
a day of the month.
The criteria doesn't just say,
any number between 1 and 31.
It has to be the day of the
month of his birthday.
So we have to kind of pick, we
have to say, let's assume that
his birthday is the 14th.
If his birthday is the 14th,
and this is the day of the
month of his birthday, then 20
is of course not the day of
the month of his birthday.
So it doesn't satisfy
this criterion.
It only satisfies times 5.
So that's how you have to think
about it, and I have to
completely admit that I think
that this is a little bit of a
too nuanced question.
Out of the five tests we've done
so far, this is the first
one that I had to take a little
bit of off time to
figure out on my own.
Let's move on to the next
problem, now that we have that
one out of the way.
Problem number 14.
Just hope you don't face that
when you take the SAT.
Square root of x plus 9
is equal to x minus 3.
And they say, for all values
of x greater than 3, the
equation above is equivalent
to which of the following?
Let's see where this goes.
So let's square both sides
of this equation.
Let's square both sides,
just to get rid of
the square root sign.
So the left hand side-- I'm
going to switch colors--
becomes x plus 9.
And then we just have to
multiply that out, so that
becomes x squared-- x
times x-- and then
minus 6x plus 9, right?
You have x times minus 3 is
minus 3x, and when you
multiply it again, you
get minus 3x again.
And if you don't remember how to
do this, you might want to
just multiply it x minus
3 times x minus 3.
Going back to this, so
this is the relation.
And they want us to write
in terms of x.
So let's subtract 9
from both sides.
We get x is equal to
x squared minus 6x.
And that is choice C.
And we are done.
And the reason why they said x
is greater than 3 is because
they actually-- well, they
didn't want you to take the
negative square root, right?
They wanted you to make sure
that this is the positive
square root.
Next problem, problem 15.
How many integers in the set of
all integers from 1 to 100
inclusive are not the square
of an integer?
So it's 1 to 100 inclusive,
so it includes 1 and 100.
So what we have to think about
is how many squares are there
between 1 and 100?
Well, 100 is 10 squared, 1 is
1 squared, so every number
between 1 and 10 squared
is going to be
in this range, right?
2 squared-- so these are the
numbers whose squares-- 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10-- and
of course, those
are 10 numbers, right?
So they're 10 numbers-- you
know, 1 squared is 1, 2
squared is 4-- all of these
numbers are going to be
between 1 and 100 inclusive.
So all of these numbers are
there, there's 10 of them.
So how many of them are
not a perfect square?
It's going to be 100 minus 10--
minus these 10 numbers.
So it's 90.
Which is choice E.
I'll see you in the
next video.